well I think the recession is doing two
things first it it cuts the volume of
building hugely you know the first thing
you give up in bad times is building a
new building you know you got to eat you
kind of do certain other essential
things but building a building for most
people most businesses most institutions
is an optional thing and so when times
are tough you give it up it's both
optional and unbelievably expensive so
therefore it's the first thing to go
that's the bad effect obviously of the
recession the good effect though is it
it kind of can cleanse a lot of the crap
out of a system I mean we've just come
through a period of enormous and in some
ways excessive prosperity a lot of what
we've built has been excessive and more
than a little vulgar so if if the
recession puts an end to the McMansion
it will have been a social good in some
way actually that's not too I don't mean
to be flippant about it obviously there
is more social ill to a recession than
social good but somewhere within all the
awful stuff there'll be a modest silver
lining and that might be that we will
begin to understand that you know an
upper middle-class prosperous family of
four does not require 15,000 square feet
of living space as a bare minimum which
is the way a lot of the country has been
operating in the age of the McMansion
the recession's affected architecture at
all levels I think because there's not
much money to build remember a
commercial building nobody builds with
their own money it's all money that gets
lent by financial institutions and
they're not doing it right now in this
climate so buildings at all levels have
been affected the government is not
building much commercial developers are
not building much about the only amount
of building that you do see is some
institutional building academic
institutions cultural institutions
perhaps that have been planning projects
for a long time have raised a lot of the
money they need through private
philanthropy and are also figuring that
you know with construction way down this
is actually a good time because they can
build it at a cheaper price and they
might if things come back in a couple
years so they're going ahead with a
certain number of projects but an awful
lot of stuff is not happening in that
category as well as other categories so
it's it's way down at at all levels well
you know we're coming out of this period
when architecture has been incredibly
ambitious and sometimes too ambitious
even but although far be it from me as
an architecture critic to say there's
such a thing as architecture being too
ambitious but in fact sometimes it has
been it's tried too hard it's sort of
acted as if it was going to solve all
the world's ills by a bunch of fancy
buildings any case I think we are
pulling back on a lot of that stuff and
there there's both a good and a bad side
also the good side is sometimes of
things are being done just in a more
simple clear basic way without a lot of
unnecessary frills and fuss you know it
kind of maybe we'll get back to a
respect for kind of modernist purity
sometimes and that's all to the good the
other hand if things are just done more
cheaply with crappy junkie materials
that's not to the good and I think we're
seeing some of both of those things
right now